OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON WE'RE GONNA
START OR HEARING FOR TWO DAME.
WELCOME. TODAY WE ONLY HAVE ONE
DISCUSSION ITEM ON THE AGENDA IN
ADDITION WE HAVE A NON
DISCUSSION LIST OF ITEMS THAT
MEMBERS MAY ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT
. AND THE PUBLIC MAY PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. REACH OUT IN
THE SPEAKERS ARE LISTED IN
SPEAKING ORDER. FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BEGIN WITH THOSE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM FOLLOWED BY
PHONE TESTIMONY. EACH PERSON
WILL HAVE TO ONE MINUTE TO
SPEAK. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT THIS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD ALSO BE ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE STREAMING
THIS HEARING. THE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN IN THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND A STAFF MEMBER
WILL ASSIST YOU THE NUMBER FOR
THE COMMITTEE ACE NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE
NINE WE WILL NOT BE TAKING ANY
VOTES TODAY. I WILL FIRST AS
MEMBERS OF THE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ON ANY OF THE ITEMS
LISTED ON THE NON DISCUSSION
SECTION WE DO HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALLEY- AND
DEPARTMENT OF REPRESENTATIVES
AVAILABLE ON WEBEX. DO ANY OF
THE MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ON AND THAT NON DISCUSSION
SECTIONS. OKAY IN THAT CASE
WE'LL MOVE ON TO ISSUE ONE ON
THE EXTENT IS A SPECIAL THANKS
TO THE PANELISTS FOR JOINING US
IN THE HEARING ROOM TODAY AND WE
HAVE ONE PANELIST ON JOINING US
REMOTELY FROM ALLEY EACH
PANELIST IS LISTED IN THE
SPEAKING ORDER YOUR PANELISTS
PLEASE PROCEED. AND ONCE- THE
PANEL IS DONE IF THE NEXT PERSON
COULD JUST CONTINUE. YOU DO NOT
HAVE TO WAIT FOR ME TO PROMPT
YOU. WE WILL SAVE QUESTIONS AT
THE END FOR THE END OF THE PANEL
. AND SO OUR FIRST PANEL IS ON
PATHWAYS TO HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
YOUNG ADULTS. THANK YOU. AND
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY IT'S
REALLY WONDERFUL TO BE HERE AND-
WE'RE HERE TO SHARE WITH YOU
ABOUT- SOME REALLY EXCITING
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING AND
I'M IN CALIFORNIA WOULD YOU NOT
JUSTICE AND A HUGE FOCUS THAT.
HAS STARTED TO. GAIN MOMENTUM IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS MOVING
TOWARDS HIGHER EDUCATION I'M AND
SPECIFICALLY WITH YOUNG PEOPLE
AND THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
TO HAVE ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION. I SO I'M K<c.cyan> BLESSED</c>
AND I'VE BEEN AT USE LAWCENTER
FOR THE LAST COUPLE YEARS BUT
PRIOR TO WORKING AT USE
LAWCENTER. I WAS WORKING AT THE
COLLEGE OF SAN MATTEO AND
STARTED A PROGRAM CALLED PROJECT
CHANGE- WHICH IS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION AND MAKE A TRANSITION-
FROM BEING IN JUVENILE DETENTION
FACILITIES TO COMING TO THE
COLLEGE CAMPUS- AND MUCH OF THAT
I ALSO JUST GREW OUT OF MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE HAVING BEEN
INCARCERATED THE MAJORITY OF MY
HIGH SCHOOL EXPERIENCE- AND
GETTING MY HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
AND FIGHTING TO GET IT WHILE I
WAS IN THESYSTEM- AND WHILE I
WAS. IN JUVENILE HALL THIS IS IN
THE NINETIES- THEY DIDN'T HAVE
HIGHER EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND IT
WAS VERY CLEAR TO ME- ONCE I
MADE THE TRANSITION MYSELF- TO.
OBTAINING A HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
MYSELF AND- ENDING UP TEACHING
AT THE COLLEGE OF SAN MATEO THAT
I REALLY NEED TO MAKE THIS
AVAILABLE FOR OTHER YOUNG PEOPLE
SO THAT THEY WOULDN'T HAVE TO
STRUGGLE. THROUGHTHE
EXPERIENCES OF TRYING TO
NAVIGATE THE HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM- AND WITH US TODAY OUR
STUDENTS WHO HAVE GONE THROUGH
THE EXPERIENCE OF THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND GOING FORWARD- TO
GETTING THEIR DEGREES AND I'M
ALSO CURRENTLY IN THEON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO OBTAIN
THEIR DEGREE- SO WE HAVE A
WHOLE- SWATH OF EXAMPLES- BUT
IT'S BEEN REALLY POWERFUL TO
WATCH WHAT HAPPENS- WHEN THIS
CAN BECOME AVAILABLE FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE I'M TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO PATHWAYS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION- AND THEN TO. LASTLY
THERE'S BEEN A HUGE NETWORK
THAT'S GROWN I'M IN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS FOR THIS FOCUS
AMBER WE HAVE COLLEGES ALL
ACROSS THE STATE WHO ARE TRYING
TO DO THIS WORK- AND MAKE SURE
THAT. HIGHER EDUCATION IS
ACCESSIBLE AND FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND SO- WE'RE AT A POINT NOW
WHERE WITH THE CLOSURE OF DJJ
AND THE REALIGNMENT BILL- WE
HAVE A REALLY UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE ABLE TO GRAB HOLD- OF
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE ONE I
SHARED WITH YOU BUT OF COURSE-
THE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT ARE OUT
IN OUR- IN OUR STATE THAT ARE
DOING THIS WORK TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE. NOT
FIGHTING TO HAVE ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITIES. THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME'S NICK A NECKLACE YEAH SO
I'M THE- YOUTH VOICE POLICY
COACH FOR FRESH I FUNDS FOR
YOUTH. I'M ALSO A UCLA ALUM AND
A CALL TO SUBMIT TO A PROJECT
CHANGE ALONE- AND ACTUALLY I DID
UC CENTER SACRAMENTO- AND I HAD
I HAD SOME FRIENDS THAT WERE IN
YOUR YOUR OFFICE AS A MEMBER SO
AND THEN- ACTUALLY MY OLD
INTERNSHIP COORDINATOR- WORKS
FOR YOU NOW AS A MEMBER MUCH
THAT. AND I WAS ACTUALLY IN YOUR
YOUR OFFICE RECENTLY. I GIVE YOU
THE A GROUP OF YOUTH THE TOUR-
AND WE WENT THERE. L. IT THE
GREAT- AS A AS A PERFORMING ARTS
CITY STUDENT I WOULD HAVE GONE
TO COLLEGE WITHOUT PROJECT
CHANGE IT WASN'T SOMETHING THAT
WAS WAS ON MY LIST OF PLANS- I
WAS I WAS VERY MUCH ENTRENCHED
IN THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE- IN SCHOOL TO ME WAS
THIS A PLACE WHERE I RECEIVED
MORE PUNISHMENT IT WAS IT WAS A
PUNITIVE SYSTEM- I ACTUALLY GOT
INCARCERATED ON A SCHOOL CAMPUS-
FROM BEING POLICED IN MY
COMMUNITY AND BEING POLICE IN MY
SCHOOL THAT ALL STARTED WITH A
GETTING DETENTIONS AND
SUSPENSIONS OR WHATEVER FOR.
BEHAVIOR OR- GETTING TO FIGHTS
LIKE THINGS THAT LITTLE BOYS DO
RIGHT- WHICH LED ME TO BEING
INCARCERATED WHEN I WAS FOURTEEN
YEARS OLD I WAS LIKE FIVE FOOT
TWO AND A HUNDRED TWENTY POUNDS-
I THINK- NO CHILD SHOULD GO GO
TO JAIL LIKE THAT- AND IT WASN'T
UNTIL I CAME INTO. CONTACT THE
PROJECT CHANGE THAT I BELIEVE
THAT COLLEGE WAS AN OPTION FOR
ME- AND ONCE I GOT THERE I. I
STARTED THE STUDENT CLUBS I WAS
THE PRESIDENT OF THAT FOR ABOUT
TWO YEARS- AND THEN MY LAST YEAR
KATIE ACTUALLY HIRED ME TO BE A
PROGRAM AMBASSADOR. I GET PAID
TO DO THE WORK THAT I WAS DOING-
ALLOWED ME TO TRANSFER TO UCLA.
I GOT SUPER INVOLVED IN
STATEWIDE- FORMING CURSORY
LEADERSHIP- AND IT REALLY
CHANGED THE TRAJECTORY OF MY
LIFE- AND SO NOW PART OF WHAT I
DO IS I BRING YOUNG PEOPLE TO
THE CAPITAL- SHOW THEM HOW
EVERYTHING WORKS- TEACH YOU
ABOUT THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT- AND HELP
THEM BE ADVOCATES FOR. FOR THEIR
OWN FUTURE I IN AND GIVE THEM
THOSE TOOLS- AND THIS REALLY
WOULD HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE WITHOUT
PROJECT CHANGE- IN GOING FORWARD
I'M- I HATE TO SAY ABOUT ME GO
BACK TO GRAD SCHOOL- IN A
PROBABLY GET INTO YOU KNOW
TEACHING IN GET INTO HIGHER ED-
AND DO MORE OF THIS WE'RE GOING
FORWARD AND ALWAYS STAY IN THE
IN THE- JUVENILE JUSTICE FROM-
THANK YOU FOR. FOR LETTING US
COME IN AND SHARE STORIES AND BE
HERE WITH YOU TODAY AND I'LL GO
AHEAD AND PASS IT ACTUALLY. HI
GUYS IT'S A PLEASURE MY NAME IS
ASHLEY HARRIS- I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH FOR
HAVING US HERE IT'S A BIG
BLESSING OR ME- BUT YEAH COMING
IN FOURTH IN KIND OF GOING BACK
ON TO WHAT NICK HAS SAID. I'VE
ALSO BEEN- IN THE INCARCERATED
SYSTEM TO GROWING UP- I HAVEN'T
HAD MY PARENTS GROWING UP SO
IT'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT
HAVING LIKE A SUPPORT SYSTEM AND
YOU KNOW PEOPLE YOU CAN LIKE
RELY ON- AND SO. COMING OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL WHICH I DIDN'T THINK
I WAS EVER GOING TO GRADUATE
WHICH I DID I WAS ABLE TO
GRADUATE ON STAGE- FOR AMERICAN
HIGH SCHOOL- AND COMING OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL AND NOT KNOWING LIKE
WHERE TO GO WHERE TURN TO EVEN
IF I HAVE. OPTIONS AVAILABLE FOR
ME JUST BECAUSE- WHEN YOU GET IN
TROUBLE YOU. THINK YOU THERE'S
NOTHING ELSE LEFT OUT THERE FOR
YOU FUTURE WHY IS- YOU KNOW
PERSONALITY WISE AND- PROJECT
CHANGE WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
ABLE TO LIKE OPEN MY EYES AND
SEE THAT PEOPLE MAKE MISTAKES
AND THERE'S- YOU KNOW NOTHING
WRONG WITH. STILL ACHIEVING AND
STILL ATTEMPTING YOUR CALLS
BECAUSE THE WORST THAT CAN
HAPPEN IF SOMEBODY COULD JUST
TELL YOU KNOW- SO YEAH THIS
PROGRAM IS JUST DEFINITELY BEEN
LIKE A BIG EYE OPENER AND YOU
KNOW. BIG BLESSING FOR MY LIFE-
AS I GET TO MEET NEW PEOPLE AND-
YOU KNOW SHARE MY STORIES AND
HELP PEOPLE AND YOU KNOW HOW
THAT SUPPORT SYSTEM THERE YOU
KNOW IF THAT MAKES SENSE. AND SO
IT'S JUST BEEN A BLESSING TO
HAVE KATIE AND NICK AND-
EVERYBODY BECAUSE LIKE WITHOUT
THEM I. DON'T KNOW WHY BUT- YEAH
IT'S A IT'S A GREAT PROGRAM AND
I JUST I DON'T KNOW WHERE. I
WOULD BE WITHOUT THESE PEOPLE SO
IT'S A BLESSING TO HAVE HAVE-
AND- EVERYBODY HERE LISTENING.
SO I DO APPRECIATE YOU GUYS
TAKING THE TIME TO LISTEN. SO
KEY UP. WE ALSO HAVE ON A WEBEX
JACKIE RODRIGUEZ. WHO IT WILL BE
SPEAKING NEXT CAN WE- HOWEVER
COME THROUGH. CHECK YOUR YOU
THEIR- I'M HERE AND MY VIDEO IS
ON TO I'M NOT SURE IF YOU'RE
ABLE TO SEE ME. REGAL YES-
EIGHT. PLEASURE TO BE HERE I'M
SORRY I COULDN'T BE THERE N
PERSON BUT IT'S ALWAYS A
PLEASURE TO BE ABLE. TO BE HERE
THE PROJECT CHANGE- MY NAME IS
JACQUELINE RODRIGUEZ I AM
CURRENTLY. SENIOR GRADUATING IN
JUNE FROM UCLA. I AM A PARENTING
STUDENTS AT I AM ALSO A- JUST
TELL PROJECT CHANGE ALUMNI. SO
IT'S DEFINITELY A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE AND ALWAYS TO ADVOCATE- FOR
PROJECT CHANGE BECAUSE- CHANGE
IS THE REASON THAT I AM WHERE I
AM TODAY. I CAME FROM A VERY
NONTRADITIONAL BACKGROUND I
ENTERED THAT ARE JUST AS SOMEONE
I WAS TWELVE YEARS OLD WHEN. I
WAS INCARCERATED IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE I WAS THE
YOUNGEST ONE IN CLASS- OBVIOUSLY
I WAS IN SEVENTH GRADE ALL THE
GIRLS WERE FRESHMAN SOPHOMORE
JUNIORS SO YOU PATIENT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT AND THERE I WOULD GET
YOU KNOW. RENDON STUDIES WORK TO
DO IN THE BACK ALL THE I NEVER
HAD ACCESS TO REALLY GOOD
EDUCATION FOR ME. BUT WHEN I GOT
LEASE- I ANSWER A- CONTINUATION
SCHOOL EVEN THOUGH I HAD ALL THE
CREDIT TO GO TO A REGULAR HIGH
SCHOOL. I WENT TO CONTINUATION
SCHOOL. LAW WAS THERE I WAS ABLE
TO DO CONCURRENT ENROLLMENT
WHICH WAS REALLY GREAT BECAUSE
COMING FROM THE BACKGROUND LIKE
ME AND GOING INTO A COLLEGE UP
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD SOMETHING I
NEVER THOUGHT I WAS ABLE TO DO.
WAS SUCH AN EYE OPENER FOR ME
BECAUSE- YOU TO KNOW THAT I. WAS
ABLE TO ENTER THIS SPACE AS
WELL- I JUST DON'T HAVE THAT
MANY RESOURCES AT THE TIME AND I
ENDED UP GETTING PREGNANT WHEN I
WAS SIXTEEN. SO I PRETTY MUCH
DROPPED OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL I
DIDN'T HAVE. THE RESOURCES AND-
AFTER MY SECOND CHILD I KNEW
THAT IN ORDER TO NOT GO TO THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE IN
ORDER TO BETTER MY- FUTURE. WELL
HOW TO PURSUE HIGHER EDUCATION.
SO WHEN I ENTERED COLLEGE WAS ON
THE TAIL I ACTUALLY MET A
STUDENT WHO I USED TO BE
INCARCERATED WITH. AND HE TOLD
ME ALL ABOUT TO CHANGE. AND AS
SOON AS I GOT INVOLVED WITH
PROJECT CHANGE IT COMPLETELY
CHANGED MY LIFE FOR THE BETTER.
I HAD SO MUCH COMMUNITIES SO
MANY PEOPLE SUPPORTING ME SO
MANY PEOPLE ARE JUST LIKE ME
WHERE AND WE THOUGHT WE WERE
NEVER EVEN GOOD ENOUGH TO ENTER
THE SPACE IT. THANK YOU TAKE THE
PROJECT CHANGE I WAS ABLE TO DO
SO MUCH ADVOCACY I ACTUALLY
TESTIFIED FOR SB SEVEN ONE SIX.
I WAS ABLE TO GO TO CONFERENCES
FOR FORMERLY INCARCERATED
STUDENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY- I
WAS ABLE TO TRANSFER TO UCLA
WHICH SOMETHING I NEVER THOUGHT
I WAS GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO.
AND I CAN TRULY SAY THAT I WOULD
NOT BE HERE. IF IT WASN'T FOR
PROJECT CHANGE. NOW I.
GRADUATING FROM YOU SEE. I AM
ACTUALLY TAKING OUTSIDE THIS
YEAR. AND APPLYING TO LAW SCHOOL
I'M HOPE TO. GET INVOLVED WITH-
GET. KEEP GETTING A OUR WOULD
YOU WANNA JUST IS HOPEFULLY GET
INVOLVED. ALMOST BECOMING AN
ATTORNEY FOR DOING ALSO SO.
EXCITED TO BE HERE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING US AND LIKE I
SAID IF IT WASN'T FOR PROJECT
CHANGE I WOULD NOT BE WHERE I AM
TODAY SO THANK. I THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT OUT WE DO HAVE-
I HAVE QUESTIONS AND I'M AM SURE
MY COLLEAGUES TAT QUESTION BUT
BEFORE WE WENT INTO THIS
QUESTIONS IF I COULD GO BACK TO
MISS BLISS CAN YOU. TALK TO A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT- HOW THE
PROGRAM WORKS A LITTLE MORE
DETAILS AND SURE- SO THE
STRUCTURE OF THE PROGRAM IT'S-
BASED IN A COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND
THAT'S A THAT'S A VERY
PURPOSEFUL AS WELL BECAUSE MANY
YOUNG PEOPLE- WHO WERE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IMPACTED- HAVE A
DISJOINTED EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE OR- YOU KNOW IN AND
OUT OF FACILITIES- IN AND OUT OF
SCHOOL. YOU KNOW VARIOUS
SCHOOLS- AND SO GOING RIGHT INTO
A UC OR CSU OR PRIVATE
UNIVERSITY RIGHT AFTER COLLEGE
I'M SOMETIMES IS VERY
CHALLENGING- AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE YOU KNOW A WEALTH
OF BENEFITS AS MANY OF US NOW-
BUT SO THE STRUCTURE OF THE
PROGRAM IS THAT. THERE IS BOTH
AN ON CAMPUS COMPONENTS- WHERE
THERE'S A HUGE A SUPPORT SYSTEM
ON THE CAMPUS AND THEN THERE'S
ALSO- SUPPORT WITHIN DETENTION
FACILITIES AND ALTERNATIVE AND
CORDON COMMUNITY SCHOOLS SO WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE- PROFESSORS GO
INTO THE JUVENILE HALL- AND
TEACH CLASSES AND THIS IS ALSO
AT THIS POINT SINCE COBIT HYBRID
WHERE THERE'S- ONLINE COURSES
THAT ARE MADE AVAILABLE AND
STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING UC CSU
TRANSFERABLE COURSES WHICH IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT- FOR TO BE
CREDIT BEARING- IT'S ALSO DUAL
ENROLLMENT- COURSES WHICH IS A
HUGE- PIECE OF THE PROGRAM IS.
THAT YOU THINK PEOPLE ARE
STARTING THEIR EDUCATIONAL
JOURNEY AT A YOUNG AGE- AND AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER WITH THE-
ASPECT OF YOUNG PEOPLE BEING-
CREDIT DEFICIENT- AS PART OF.
WHAT HAPPENS- THIS IS ALSO
INSTEAD OF POSITIVE SHIFT-
TOWARDS HAVING THEIR CREDITS BE
AT COLLEGE AND HIGH SCHOOL AT
THE SAME TIME VERSUS WHAT I
THINK IS TRADITIONALLY BEEN DONE
WHERE IT'S INDEPENDENT STUDY. OR
ADULT SCHOOL I'M SAID THIS SHIFT
SENT TO- HAVING AGAIN ALL OF
THAT COMPONENTS THAT COME WITH
BEING PART OF- A COLLEGE
ATMOSPHERE WHERE IT'S POSITIVE-
IDENTITY AND IT'S ALSO A MESSAGE
TO YOUNG PEOPLE TO THAT. YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE ALL THESE PATHS
ARE AVAILABLE TO YOU AND ALSO WE
BELIEVE IN YOUR EDUCATION AND WE
DON'T ALSO WANT TO LIMITS- BUT
WHAT MADE OF A- TO YOU- SO%
THAT'S THE INSIDE COMPONENTS-
AND THEN THE ON CAMPUS COMPONENT
WHICH I THINK IS. A HUGE- PART
OF THE FOCUS AND AGAIN WITH THE
DJJ CLOSURE AND EVERYTHING
THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK THIS IS
ANOTHER HUGE PIECE WHICH IS
THAT- YOUNG PEOPLE ARE ON THE
CAMPUS TAKING COURSES JUST AS
ANY COLLEGE STUDENT WOULD DO BUT
THEY HAVE. A NETWORK- AND NECK
MENTIONED I'M A LITTLE BIT THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT NECK
ACTUALLY BUILT- VERY MUCH WHICH
IS WHERE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE PART
OF H. COMMUNITY BASED LEARNING-
THEY HAVE- STUDENT LEADERSHIP
AND BATTED AND A WHOLE. NETWORK
OF PEOPLE ON THE CAMPUS THAT ARE
DEEPLY DEDICATED TO THE STUDENTS
SUCCESS ALL THE WAY FROM YOU
KNOW THE CHANCELLOR TO THE
PRESIDENT TO FACULTY AND THAT'S
A BIG PART OF. THE PROGRAM
STRUCTURES THAT YOU WANT BY AND
FROM THE ENTIRE CAMPUS COMMUNITY
SAID THAT- EVERYBODY IS
SUPPORTED AND ALSO DEMYSTIFIES
FOR PEOPLE TO- WHO THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE- SINCE UNFORTUNATELY
THAT CONTINUES TO BE A STIGMA-
SO THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF THE
STRUCTURE OF THE PROGRAM. AND
HOW MANY COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CURRENTLY HAVE A MODEL SIMILAR
TO PROJECT CHANGE. THERE IT IS
BEEN THE DIRECT PROGRAM HAS BEEN
REPLICATED ACROSS THREE COLLEGE
- THEY'RE SIMILAR PROGRAMS WITH
THE RISING SCHOLARS NETWORK
ACROSS THE STATE- THERE ARE.
TWENTY SIX COLLEGES THAT HAVE
STARTED TO FOCUS ON JUVENILE
JUSTICE IN PARTICULAR- AND SO IF
YOUR- NOT AWARE AT THE RISING
SCHOLARS NETWORK- HAS REALLY
FOCUSED ON THE ADULT POPULATION-
JAILS PRISONS- BUT HAS DONE WORK
WITH YOUTH AND IN THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS HAS REALLY TURNED
THEIR ATTENTION- IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR YOU KNOW.
FOLKS SITTING HERE AND OUT IN
THE COMMUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
JUVENILE JUSTICE IS ANOTHER-
AREA THAT THERE'S ATTENTION TO.
AND FOR BEFORE THE STUDENTS ARE
FOR THE STUDENTS WHO ARE EXITING
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SOME WHO
ARE STILL NOT DONE WITH. HIGH
SCHOOL IS THERE SOMETHING. IS
THERE SOMETHING FOR THEM AS WELL
OR DO YOU IS IT JUST FOR THEM
WHEN THEY'RE AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. SO THE CALL SORRY COULD
YOU REPEAT IF I'M IF I'M- IF ON
THE SIXTEEN YEAR OLD AND I'M
STILL IN HIGH SCHOOL AND I'M I'M
EXITING. THE JUVENILE DETENTION-
WHAT'S AVAILABLE FOR THEM AND
HOW TO THE HOW TO TAP INTO
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS YES SO THAT'S
THE DUAL ENROLLMENT PIECE- WHERE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE TAKING COLLEGE
CLASSES REGARDLESS OF DIPLOMA OR
EVEN FIFTEEN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
YEARS OLD AND SO THEY CAN IN
FACT AND DUE. IN ROLL ON THE
COLLEGE CAMPUS TAKE COURSES- OR
IF THEY GO BACK TO THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL- IN THERE. AND TAKING
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL COURSES AND
THEY CAN ALSO STILL BE ENGAGED
IN ACTIVITIES THAT. ARE GOING ON
WITH THE PROGRAM OR CAN ALSO BE
TAKING COLLEGE CLASSES WHILE
THEY'RE FINISHING THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL COURSES SO THERE'S THAT-
THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF WRAPAROUND
SUPPORT SERVICES- THAT ARE MADE
AVAILABLE WITH BASIC NEEDS-
CHILD CARE TRANSPORTATION FOOD-
ACCESS TO HOUSING SO. THIS IS
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS WHETHER
THEY HAVE THEIR DIPLOMA OR DO
NOT. SOMEWHERE THE DORLAND
FEDERAL MEMBER PROGRAMS- THANK
IS. AND THEN I WANT TO ASK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
NETWORK THAT'S BEEN CREATED AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR THE
FIRST TWO MONTHS AND THEN PART
IN THAT IMPORTANT PIECE IS THERE
A NETWORK LIKE THAT THAT THE
STUDENTS GET WHEN THEY GO BACK
TO HIGH SCHOOL OR- SO THE
STUDENTS CAN STILL- YOU KNOW
COME TO CAMPUS AND BEING GAUGE
RAFTS- THE NETWORK. REALLY THE
STUDENT CLUB- THAT'S BEEN
CREATED THAT'S THE SOCIAL PEACE-
BUT ALSO AGAIN HAVING ACCESS TO
ALL THE COURSES AND BASIC NEEDS
SUPPORTS BUT THE SOCIAL ASPECT
OF BEING ABLE TO MEET REGULARLY
THERE'S A- FOR A LONG TIME
THERE'S BEEN A ONCE A WEEK-
MEETING FOR STUDENTS TO BE ABLE
TO MEET ON CAMPUS- AND DURING
COPE AND VIRTUALLY SO THAT'S THE
SUPPORT SYSTEM- AND THERE. IT
THE GOAL IS ALSO TO HAVE IT BE A
MULTIPLE ENTRY POINTS SO THAT'S
NOT LEAVING ANY YOUNG PERSON
OUT. IF THAT HELPS AND THEN FOR-
IS MY LAN I'M MORE QUESTIONS BUT
AFTER THIS ON HAND THAT OFF TO
THE COMMISSION I WAS A CLASSROOM
TEACHER FOR THIRTEEN YEARS
THAT'S WHAT- FOR ASHLEY-
JACQUELINE AND NICK- ETHNIC
SPECIFICALLY YOU TALKED ABOUT
HOW. YOU SOLVE SCHOOL IS A PLACE
OF PUNISHMENT AND- THIS IS A
PROJECT CHANGE HELP YOU CHANGE.
CHANGE THAT HOW. WHAT WAS THAT
THE ATTRACTED YOU I MEAN HOW YOU
KNOW WE HAVE LOTS OF PROJECTS
OUT THERE PROGRAMS OUT THERE FOR
INDIVIDUALS RIGHT AND THEN
THERE'S THAT. YOU YOU DECIDE AND
STICK IT ON EACH OF IT AND SO
I'M EXCITED THAT WE HAVE THESE
EXAMPLES WITH THE THREE OF YOU
WHAT WAS SPECIAL ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM TO CONVINCE YOU TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE. OF IT. YEAH SO I
THINK FIRST OF ALL ESPECIALLY
LIKE I USED TO FOR ME AND I
THINK IT'S TRUE FOR THIS
POPULATION IN GENERAL I THINK
YOU KNOW K. THROUGH TWELVE YOU
REALLY JUST IN SURVIVAL MODE YOU
DON'T REALLY HAVE THE MOST
CONTROL OVER YOUR ENVIRONMENT-
OVER LIKE WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
YOUR LIFE AS AN ADULT YOU GAIN A
LITTLE BIT MORE- WHAT IS IT WHAT
WHAT SORT FOR THAT- YOU EVEN
AGENCY GET GET MORE AGENCY
RIGHT- AND SO I THINK WHEN I WAS
APPROACHED BY IT BY PROJECT
CHANGE AND THEY'RE LIKE OH LIKE
YOU CAN GO TO SCHOOL FOR FREE.
AS A- FOR FREE WITH THE CIRCUS
OUTBREAKS I HAD THIS CONCEPTION
I I'D I KNEW NOTHING ABOUT
COLLEGE COMMUNITY COLLEGE STATE
SCHOOL UC'S ANYTHING- AND SO IN
MY HEAD- COLLEGES SOMETHING YOU
DID IF YOU WERE RICH RIGHT- EVEN
AT THE COMMUNITY LEVEL IS LIKE
THAT'S PROBABLY TOO MUCH FOR ME
YOU KNOW RIGHT- AND SO HAVING
THAT COMPONENT WHERE- IT WAS
FREE THAT WAS THAT WAS HUGE AND
THEN ALSO HAVING LIKE MENTOR
SHIP- HAVING LIKE- THE PEOPLE TO
ROUTE TO RELY ON ON CAMPUS AS
WELL- A BIG THING FOR ME WHAT
WAS IT WHERE ALL THE WARM HAND
OFF SO WE CAME ON TO CAMPUS AND-
COUNTRY DUE TO EVERYBODY FROM
FINANCIAL AID TO GUIDANCE
COUNSELORS TO PROFESSORS- I WAS-
GIVEN A MENTOR. ON CAMPUS AS
WELL WHO IS A PROFESSOR OF FILM
PROFESSOR- AND SO THOSE THOSE
ARE KEY COMPONENTS- REALLY
CHANGED FOR ME AND THEN ONCE WE
GOT THE STUDENT CLUB GOING IN-
AND HAD EVERYBODY INVOLVED AND
STUFF THAT WAS THAT WAS GREAT
BECAUSE AND I BUILT IT I CAMPUS
COMMUNITY COULD SOMETHING THAT
ALSO HAPPENS- SPECIFICALLY THIS
POPULATION WHEN PEOPLE START
GETTING THEIR LIVES TOGETHER
RIGHT- YOU HAVE TO CUT OFF
PEOPLE AND YOU HAVE TO IT GETS A
LITTLE LONELY- SERVER REBUILDING
LIKE- POSITIVE- SOCIAL
ENVIRONMENT- IS REALLY KEY AND
THEN SO THEN. YOU KNOW WE'RE
GOING BOWLING AND HIKING AND.
ALL THAT SO IS IT WAS COOL. YEAH
SO I CAN I CAN OF ELABORATE.
THAT SAME. WAY NICK IT'S YOU
KNOW. YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE KIND OF
CONFUSED WHEN HE WANTS TO COME
OUT OF OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL IT'S
KIND OF. LIKE YOU KNOW LIKE.
WHAT WHAT DO YOU DO IN A WAY-
AND SO. FOR ME IT'S ALSO. KIND
OF THE SAME THING I AND- YOU
KNOW. HAVING CAME FROM YOU KNOW
pOF PUTS IN YOUR MIND WILL YOU
KNOW. IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONEY YOU KNOW
YOU CAN'T GET THAT CERTAIN
MANAGE EDUCATION YOU KNOW THAT
YOU NEED- TOO YOU KNOW. PURSUED
YOU KNOW WHATEVER DEGREE OR YOU
KNOW PATH YOU CHOOSE TO TAKE-
BUT IT'S- FOR ME IT'S NOT JUST.
SO MUCH OF. THEM HELPING ME LIKE
FINANCIALLY WITH LIKE MY SCHOOL
IT'S MORE OF LIKE THE SUPPORT
AND HAVING THESE. THE SAME
PEOPLE GOING THROUGH THE EXACT
SAME THING. YOU KNOW THAT I'M
GOING THROUGH AND IT'S YOU KNOW
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I LIKE TO
BUILD WITH PEOPLE. AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT THIS THIS PROGRAM
IS THIS IT'S- YOU KNOW THEY- WE
CAN BUILD YOU KNOW FROM. THE
BOTTOM UP AND- THEY NEVER GIVE
UP AND THAT'S JUST ONE THING
THAT YOU KNOW STANDS OUT TO ME
TOO. AS KATIE NEVER GIVES UP ON
US SHE- WILL FIGHT. TILL THE END
FOR US. OKAY ONE MORE THING SEE
HOW. AT THINK THAT THAT'S ALL
REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF THE
PROGRAM MODEL IS IT IT'S NON
PUNITIVE SO. THERE THERE ARE
OTHER PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS AT
COMMUNICABLE JUST LIKE YOUR P.
OR UPS RIGHT. BUT YOU HAVE TO
MEET CERTAIN CRITERIA IS YOU
HAVE TO TAKE A CERTAIN AMOUNT
UNITS YOU NEED LIKE A CERTAIN
GPA- AND THAT AND I THINK THAT
THAT DETERS A LOT OF THIS
POPULATION- BECAUSE F YOU CAN
POTENTIALLY HAVE. THESE THESE
PRIVILEGES REVOKED SOME PEOPLE
JUST DON'T WANT TO TOUCH IT
BECAUSE THEY'VE ALREADY HAD SO
MANY NEGATIVE EXPERIENCES WITH
WITH PROGRAMS RIGHT. WHERE THEY
THEY'RE LIKE OH WE GOT YOU AND
THEN THEY THEY ABANDONED YOU- SO
THIS THIS THAT PART OF THE
PROGRAM MODEL IS A KEY-
PROBABLY. THE BIGGEST. YES
THAT'S- I NEXT THING YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT. SOMETHING I DEFINITELY
WANTED TO TOUCH UPON. SO
SOMETHING THAT REALLY DREW ME.
PROJECT CHANGE WAS. ABSOLUTELY
THE COMMUNITY BECAUSE FOR ME. IT
WAS DIFFICULT ENOUGH I MEAN I
WANT TO SAY LIKE I MENTIONED I
GOT INCARCERATED WHEN I WAS
TWELVE I WAS IN SEVENTH GRADE.
WHEN I. LEAST I PRETTY MUCH GOT
OFF PROBATION AND I GOT PREGNANT
RIGHT AWAY SO I DROPPED OUT. AND
I DIDN'T BOTHER TO GO BACK TO
HIGH SCHOOL OR TO GET MY GED.
YOU TO GO STRAIGHT TO COLLEGE
AND START MY CAREER AND I WANT
TO DO EVERYTHING MY POWER TO DO
SO. BUT I DIDN'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES I'M A FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS SO I COULDN'T
CALL MY PARENTS I MEAN. I COULD
CALL AND SAY HEY WHAT DO I DO
HOW DO I SIGN UP. APPLYING TO
COLLEGES ON THE TAIL AND EVEN
THOUGH IT'S COMING COLLEGE I WAS
NERVOUS THAT WASN'T EVEN GOING
TO GET ACCEPTED. ONE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN THE FIRST PERSON I
SEE IN MY FIRST CLASS IS A
PERSON I WAS INCARCERATED WITH
AND- I CAN PRODUCE TO THE
COMMUNITY A PROJECT CHANGE AND
EVERYTHING THEY HAVE TO OFFER-
YOU KNOW KATIE NEVER GIVING UP
ON US MAKING IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
YOU TO FAIL LIKE. ANYTHING I
NEEDED KATIE WAS THERE FROM THE
BEGINNING ALL OF MY PROJECT
CHANGE COMMUNITY WAS THERE- YOU
KNOW JUST SEEING EVERYONE DOING
SO GREAT DOING SO MUCH ADVOCATE
SEE. US GETTING BACK TO THE
JUVENILE HALLS WE WERE
INCARCERATED IN AND SPEAKING TO
THE YOUTH AND NOW WHAT PROJECT
CHANGE. WITH YOUR FOR ME. AND
YOU KNOW SOMEONE COULD TRANSFER
OVER TO UCLA I REMEMBER TEXTING
LIKE OH MY GOODNESS IT'S MY TURN
TO APPLY AND- YOU KNOW HE WAS
ALWAYS THERE ALSO JUST YOU KNOW
THE COMMUNITY JUST CONTINUED AND
CONTINUED. ACTOR AND- THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WAS HUGE FOR ME
BECAUSE I. DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
WHERE TO START. ALL SEVEN GREAT
TO STRAIGHT TALK. I WAS WONDER.
FROM THE EDUCATION ADVERSITY
ENJOY HALL. AND BUILDING
COMMUNITY AND HAVING THE
RESOURCES HAVING SOMEONE FROM
EVERY SINGLE DEPARTMENTS ON
FINANCIAL AID COUNSELING YOU
NAME IT- THEY'RE ALWAYS THERE
FOR US HAVING COAL PORTS IN
CLASSROOMS I WAS ALWAYS GREAT.
AND I JUST SEEING EVERYBODY SO
GREAT THAT WERE ONCE WE WERE
ONCE IN A SITUATION HERE WE
NEVER THOUGHT THIS WAS POSSIBLE.
AND SEEN PEOPLE IN PROJECT
CHANGE SEEN THEM TRANSFER OVER
TO YOU SEE CSU. IT JUST MADE ME
FEEL LIKE I COULD BE THAT PERSON
TO DO IT TOO AND- NOW HERE I AM
THAT PERSON DOING IT SO. I'M
BEYOND GRATEFUL FOR EVERYTHING
THAT PARTY CHANGES ON FOR ME.
THIS DOES SOUND REALLY GOOD AND
ENCOURAGING AND I'M I'M KIND OF
CURIOUS BECAUSE AT AT SOME POINT
THE LIGHT BULB HIT. FOR THE
THREE OF YOU KNOW OR QUALITY OF
WORK HERE- EVEN THOUGH YOU YOU.
WANNA BERRIES MAY HAVE BEEN
FINANCIAL YOU STILL GOT TO DO
THE WORK. STILL RASHTRAPATI
CLASS YOU STILL GOTTA TURN YOUR
HOMEWORK YOU STILL GOTTA TRY TO
KEEP UP WITH THE CLASS. AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE. YOU HAD A
COMMUNITY. OF FOLK. A WRAPAROUND
SERVICES IS LIKE WE LIKE TO CALL
IT- THAT WAS EITHER CREATED OR
EMBEDDED. BUT IT. I KNOW YOU
TALK ABOUT. THE FINANCIAL PART
BUT WHAT REALLY WAS THE LIGHT.
THAT MADE YOU SAY. I'M GONNA
FINISH THIS THIS IS THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. NO MATTER WHAT
BECAUSE WHAT I HEAR IN YOUR
VOICE AT SOME POINT. YOU'RE
GOING TO DO THIS NO MATTER WHAT
AND- AND THEN MY SECOND THING IS
YOU KNOW. SO YOU DON'T MAKE A
SECOND MISTAKE USC ALSO HAS
PROGRAMS IN PLACE. EVEN APPLY TO
ALSO- BUT BUT BUT SERIOUSLY IT
IS. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THAT
WE STRUGGLE ON PUBLIC SAFETY IS
WHAT IS IT. THAT THAT WILL GET
YOU ON THE RIGHT ROAD AND PATH
AND WE EVEN HEARD YOU SAY. YOU
DELIBERATELY SET I AM NOW WITH
ANOTHER GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO
SHARE THE SAME VALUES AND GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES. N. AND YOU HAVE
TO BALANCE A PUSH THEM AWAY BUT
YOU HAD TO CONDUCT. GET THEM OUT
OF YOUR LIFE AND HAVE NEW
ACQUAINTANCES FRIENDS AND
MENTORS AND- AS OPPOSED TO WHAT
WAS HAPPENING BEFORE. BUT
THERE'S GOT. TO BE AN ENGINE- I
GREW UP WHERE I KNEW I WAS GOING
TO GO TO COLLEGE EVERYBODY THAT
WAS AROUND THE GOING TO GO TO
COLLEGE WHEN AFFECTED WASN'T A
QUESTION WHEN I WAS GOING TO GO
TO COLLEGE. IS WHEN I WAS GOING
TO GO TO HARVARD YALE USC OR LSU
AND UCLA I KNEW I WAS GOING TO
GO THE COMPETITION WAS WHICH
COLLEGE YOU'RE GOING TO GO TO
WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL. BUT I
WAS AROUND THAT SAME GROUP OF
FRIENDS THAT HAD THE SAME. NINE
TAINTED THAT FELT THE SAME WAY
AND SO HOW HOW CAN YOU GO FROM.
ONE KIND OF SET OF FRIENDS
SITUATIONS AND THEN ALL OF A
pTURNED ON TO SAID. THIS IS THE
WAY TO GO. FOR ME- WE ALL COME
INTO THIS WORLD BY OURSELVES
WE'RE ALL KIND OF LEAVE OUT OF
THIS WORLD BY OURSELVES I FEEL
LIKE FOR ME IT'S WHAT DRIVES YOU
TO MAKE YOU SUCCESSFUL WHAT'S
GOING TO BE BENEFICIAL FOR YOU
NOT NOT YOUR FRIENDS THE YOU
KNOW AT THE END OF THE DAY THEY
CAN STICK WITH YOU AND CHEER YOU
ON AND YOU KNOW WILL BE WITH YOU
AND GET TO WHERE YOU YOU KNOW
YOU WANT TO BE IN LIFE AS WELL
AS HELPING OTHERS- BUT THEN YOU.
ALSO SIT BACK AND YOU KNOW STAY
BACK WITH THEM IF THAT MAKES
SENSE AND DO NOTHING AND- I JUST
BELIEVE IT ALL DEPENDS ON HOW
SELF DRIVEN YOU ARE AND HOW MUCH
SELF CONTROL YOU KNOW YOU HAVE-
SO YEAH THAT WOULD ALWAYS IN
YOU. IT JUST READ OUT OF YOU IT
JUST IT TOOK A LITTLE BIT MORE.
FOR IT TO COME OUT TO ACTUALLY
SEE YOU KNOW OKAY I CAN ACTUALLY
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I CAN
ACTUALLY DO IT'S NOT JUST
SOMETHING THAT'S MADE UP IN MY
MIND OR- YOU KNOW SO- FOR ME I
DON'T FEEL LIKE I'M FROM ALL
THAT CREATIVE A PERSON RIGHT-
BUT I DO LIKE A PICK UP MENTORS
AND ROLE MODELS ON THE WAY AND
SO I THINK SEEN SEEN KATIE WHO
HAD HAD BEEN TO THE SYSTEM AS
WELL AND WAS NOW LEADING THIS
PROGRAM- I REALLY LOOKED UP TO
HER AND THEN- THROUGH THAT
NETWORK I MET PEOPLE LIKE ANY
REAL WHO. WHO STARTED
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS- IN SAW YOU
KNOW PEOPLE WHO WERE DOING AT AT
MULTIPLE LEVELS- IF IT REALLY
WAS THAT COMMUNITY
ACCOUNTABILITY ASPECT IN SEEING
ALL THE ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION PROVIDED- MY SECOND
SEMESTER IN- IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE I STUDIED ABROAD FOR
FREE- AND WENT TO FLORENCE AND
LEFT THE COUNTRY FOR THE FIRST
TIME- AND THAT WAS THAT WAS LIFE
CHANGING FOR ME. AND I DON'T
THINK I WOULD HAVE DONE THAT- IN
IN ANY OTHER WAY THAN- HAVING
ACCESS TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND
THOSE LIKE SCHOLARSHIP FUNDS
THAT THEY PROVIDED YOU KNOW- I
DO KNOW COMMUNITY COLLEGES DID
THAT. I DIDN'T KNOW EITHER- BUT
A V. AS- IN. UPCOMING IT'S
ACTUALLY GONNA BE IN LONDON THIS
FALL REALLY YEAH.
THAT'S GREAT. OF THE LAWYERS IN
. YEAH SO FOR ME ARE YOU HUGE
GERMAN POINT IS OBVIOUSLY MY
CHILDREN- I DON'T WANT THEM TO
GROW UP THE SAME WAY I DID-
BECAUSE I CAME FROM A GREAT HOME
MY MOM WAS A SINGLE MOTHER
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUAL SHE WAS
WORKING THREE TO FOUR JOB SO SHE
CAN BE HOME TO TAKE CARE OF ME
EVEN F SHE WANTED TO SO WE GAVE
YOU A LOT OF FREE TIME TO DO
WHAT I WANTED. SO WHO- WHICH GOT
ME IN TROUBLE SO WHEN I HAD MY%
KIDS ARE YOU KNOW IMMEDIATELY I
WAS LIKE I CANNOT PUT MY KIDS
THROUGH THE SAME THING THAT I
WENT THROUGH AND I HAVE THE
UPPER HAND BY YOU KNOW HAVING
ALL THESE RESOURCES OFFERED FOR
ME MY MOM WORKED SO HARD FOR YOU
TO BE YOU KNOW THE PERSON THAT I
AM SO I OWE IT TO MY KIDS. TO
GET THEM A BETTER LIFE AS WELL
SO THAT THEY WOULDN'T GO TO THE
SYSTEM LIKE. SO IMMEDIATE WHEN I
WENT STRAIGHT TO COLLEGE EVEN
THOUGH I HAD NO IDEA WHAT TO DO.
I KNEW THAT I WANTED TO SUCCEED
FOR MY CHILDREN AND FOR MYSELF I
OWED IT TO MYSELF AS WELL.
BECAUSE I KNEW I HAD IT IN ME I
JUST HAD TO GET IT OUT OF ME
UNLIKE YOU MENTIONED. SO FOR ME
THAT WAS MY FUTURE APPOINT AND-
JUST LOOKING UP AT PEOPLE DOING.
EVERYTHING THAT I WANTED TO DO
THAT WENT THROUGH SIMILAR
EXPERIENCES ME SOME OF THEM WANT
TO WORSE EXPERIENCES THAN ME.
AND SEEN THEM. BEING SO
SUCCESSFUL IN. ACCOMPLISHING SO
MUCH AND THAT WAS REALLY. THE
DRIVING FACTOR IF THEY CAN DO IT
I CAN DO IT. AND THEN JUST AS I
WENT TO WHEN I WAS IN JUVENILE
HALL I MEAN. I REALLY HUGE
ADVOCATE WHEN I WAS IN THERE I
WAS YOU KNOW THEY- WANTED THEY
WOULD CALL ME THE JAILHOUSE
LAWYER. ADVOCATED FOR ALL THE
GIRLS WITH WAS ABOUT PHONE.
ABOUT CERTAIN BOOKS WEREN'T
ALLOWED TO READ. GETTING I WAS
ALWAYS AN ADVOCATE BECAUSE MY
MOM TOLD ME I KNOW YOU'RE YOUNG
AND I KNOW YOU'RE IN THE SYSTEM
BUT WHAT WE SPEAK UP FOR
YOURSELF. AND THAT'S THE THAT'S
STUCK WITH ME AND WHEN I ENTERED
COLLEGE I KNEW I WANTED TO BE AN
ATTORNEY I KNEW I WANTED TO MAKE
A DIFFERENCE IN MY COMMUNITY SO
THAT INDIVIDUALS WOULDN'T GO TO
THE SAME THING AS ME SO KIDS.
COULD HAVE A BETTER OPPORTUNITY
TO RE ENVISION THEIR FUTURES AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY BELONG IN
THESE INSTITUTIONS. WELL IN
ORDER TO DO THAT. I HAVE TO
START NETWORKING I HOW TO START
ADVOCATING. ALL MANUALLY HOW TO
YOU KNOW GET IT TOGETHER I
WANTED TO GO TO YOU YOU SEE I UC
BERKELEY AND I DID EVERYTHING I
COULD TO GET THERE- I'M TALKING
FAMILIES STRUGGLING. STUDENT AND
I'VE WORKED REALLY. HAS NOT BEEN
EASY. I'VE DONE HONORS PROGRAM.
I YOU KNOW I GET PROFESSORS AT
UCLA REACH OUT TO ME I LOVE YOUR
RESEARCH- TO MAKE IT UP FOR ONE
OF THE ENGLISH DEPARTMENT
CONFERENCES. AND JUST HEARING.
THAT IS ALWAYS CONSTANT REMINDER
LIKE I NEEDED OUT. AND I'M SUCH
AN INSPIRATION I HAVE.
EVERYTHING PROJECT CHANGE TAUGHT
ME I NOW TEACH TO OTHER STUDENTS
RIGHT NOW IDEA SAM I LITERALLY
HAVE. FUND THAT'S YES I'M
CALLING ME LIKE. I'M ABOUT TO
APPLY TO UC'S WHAT DO I DO
PLEASE HELP ME AND NOW I'M THEIR
MENTOR NOW I'M MOTIVATING THEM
AND OUT ON THEIR INSPIRATION
JUST LIKE. KENNEDY ONCE MORE
INSPIRATION LIKE NICK WAS MY
INSPIRATION. SO GLAD TO BE THAT
PERSON FOR THEM AND- I WOULDN'T
BE ABLE. TO DO THAT WITHOUT ON
PURSUING HIGHER AT. THANK YOU-
IS WALDRON AND BUSINESSLIKE. HI
THANK YOU- I'M EXCITED TO HEAR
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'RE DOING
BECAUSE- I'VE BEEN WORKING IN
THE SOME OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM SPACE FOR. ALMOST TEN
YEARS. AND I ALWAYS GET
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE- THE LACK OF.
PROGRAMS YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY IN
THE CDC AND THE CHECK JUST
TRYING TO GET PEOPLE INTO THOSE
PROGRAMS AND THE FACILITIES ARE
STILL LACKING AND THINGS LIKE
THAT SO. WITH THE DJJ ISSUE WITH
THE YOU KNOW CLOSING. THE
FACILITIES AND HOW IS THAT GOING
TO IMPACT THE PROGRAM AND HOW
YOU PIVOTING AND DOING WHAT
YOU'RE DOING BECAUSE- YOU'RE-
WORKING WITH PEOPLE OR INSIDE AS
WELL AS PEOPLE ALREADY. WERE
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED. SO HOW
DOES ALL THAT HAS THE KIND OF
WORK. SO I THINK ONE OF THE-
IT'S A RICH I MEAN THAT'S SUCH A
GIFT THAT THIS IS THE SHIFT
RIGHT- AND I THINK A HUGE PART
OF THIS TO EVEN LOGISTICALLY IS
THAT THE MESSAGES IS THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE SHOULD BE IN THEIR HOME
COMMUNITIES ACCESSING SERVICES-
AND THAT'S ALSO WHAT THIS
PROGRAM IN PROGRAMS LIKE THIS.
ARE ABOUT- WHICH IS THAT IT'S
MORE ABOUT THEIR LIVES ONCE
THEY'RE IN THE COMMUNITY- IN
FACT ESPECIALLY WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE- AND OUR SHIFT IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM NOW WE
ALSO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO RE
ENVISION WHAT JUVENILE JUSTICE
LOOKS LIKE- BUT WHERE INSTEAD OF
YOUNG PEOPLE BEING AND
FACILITIES THEY CAN BE IN THEIR
HOME COMMUNITIES BEING DUALLY
ENROLLED BEING IN CLASSES HAVING
WRAPAROUND SUPPORT SERVICES AND
THERE'S A REAL OPPORTUNITY WITH
THESE THINGS HAPPENING. TO HAVE
THAT BE MORE OF THE STRUCTURE-
ESPECIALLY FOR YOU- SO THAT'S A
HUGE PART OF WHAT WE WANT TO
SHARE TODAY BECAUSE THAT'S PART
OF WHAT THE PROGRAM IS DONE AS
WELL AS YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
RELEASED EARLY TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE COURSES AT THE CAMPUS- OR
OF HAD A DIVERSION WHERE THEY'RE
NOT INCARCERATED AT ALL AND
THEY'RE INVOLVED IN COURSES AND-
DO YOU KNOW THAT SOCIAL
COMPONENT AND ALL THE WRAPAROUND
SUPPORT SERVICES. AND SO- THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT I THINK IS REALLY
EXCITING THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW TO. AFTER IS IT IT'S YOUR
QUESTION IS A LARGE SELECTION-
WELL FIRST OF ALL LET ME-
CONGRATULATE YOU ALL FOR YOUR
SUCCESS THAT THAT YOU ANY VOTE
WHAT YOU'VE OVERCOME IT IT'S
PRETTY REMARKABLE- I WOULD SAY I
HAVE TO REALLY STRONG QUESTIONS.
BECAUSE WHAT SEEMS WHAT'S BEEN
MY EXPERIENCE AND RELATING TO-
THIS PARTICULAR POPULATION THAT
WE'RE ADDRESSING HERE IS THERE'S
A LOT OF TRUST THAT'S BEEN LOST.
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS IS THERE'S
A LOT OF EARLY SETBACKS AND SELF
ESTEEM GOES WAY DOWN. AND- TO
COMPETE IN A COLLEGE ATMOSPHERE
I DON'T CARE IF IT'S COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OR NOT. IT'S HARD
ESPECIALLY IF YOU DON'T HAVE.
THE APTITUDE SKILLS LIKE WRITING
THAT JUST SOMETHING AS BASIC AS
BEING ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER A
PARAGRAPH THAT'S EANINGFUL
UNDERSTANDABLE AND- I'M TELLING
YOU IT'S NOT AN EASY SKILL TO
FIND PEOPLE WHO. GRADUATE FROM
HIGH SCHOOL MUCH LESS THOSE WHO
HAVE HAD TO SKIP SCHOOL IN
BECAUSE OF INCARCERATION OR SOME
OTHER CIRCUMSTANCE SO THE
REALITY IS YOU'VE GOT TO DEVELOP
SOME VERY POWERFUL SKILLS WITH
VERY LOW SELF CONFIDENCE. AND
THAT'S A VERY SCARY. IN RECIPE
RIGHT THERE BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
HAVE WRITING SKILLS YOU HAVE TO
ALSO HAVE STUDY SKILLS RIGHT YOU
HAVE TO REVIEW YOU HAVE TO STUDY
AND YOU ALSO. HAVE TO KNOW HOW
TO TAKE NOTES IN CLASS. RIGHT I
MEAN THESE ARE THINGS THAT
PEOPLE TAKE FOR GRANTED THAT
HAVE NOT GONE TO COLLEGE I'M
TELLING EVERYONE OF THOSE SKILLS
IF YOU DON'T HAVE ONE OF THEM.
YOU'RE YOU'RE BOUND TO HAVE
FAILURE IS WHAT OU'RE BOUND TO
HAVE. AND SO. EVEN THOUGH YOU
KNOW THESE DOORS HAVE BEEN
OPENED. YOU STILL HAVE TO
COMPETE YOU STILL HAVE TO PROVE
YOURSELF YOU STILL HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO FIND SUCCESS ECAUSE IF
YOU DON'T. THEN YOU'VE ALMOST
CREATED A DISSERVICE BECAUSE NOW
YOU'VE GOTTEN A COLLEGE YOU
PHILLIP I CAN'T DO IT. I JUST
CAN'T DO IT THAT'S A BAD
SCENARIO AND SO WHAT I'M-
CURIOUS ABOUT. IS HOW DO YOU
OVERCOME THOSE OBSTACLES WHEN
YOU HAVE THAT. PARTICULAR SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES FACING YOU BECAUSE
YOU GUYS OF SUCCESSFULLY
MANIPULATED THIS- SITUATION. AND
ESPECIALLY WITH THE LACK OF
TRUST- IT'S SUPER HARD TO SUPER
TO GET PEOPLE TO BELIEVE IN
THEMSELVES. AND I'M JUST VERY
CURIOUS AS TO HOW YOU ACCOMPLISH
THAT BECAUSE IT IS A HUGE JOB
SCHOOL BUT IT'S A REALITY I'M
NOT TRYING TO BE CRITICAL I'M
JUST BEING REAL. CONNECT CELTICS
OFFERS PLEASE- SO IT'S ACTUALLY
I THINK IT'S FUNNY THAT YOU SAY
THAT THE FIRST TIME- THE FIRST
TIME I WROTE AN ESSAY WAS IN
COLLEGE ACTUALLY- I'D I DIDN'T
KNOW EMILY FORMAT WAS I DIDN'T
KNOW HOW TO STUDY AYE AYE I KNEW
NONE OF THIS RIGHT LIKE. K<c.cyan></c>
TWELVE I WENT TO COURT COMMUNITY
SCHOOL YOU KNOW I MEAN THEY GET
THE- EDUCATION STOPPED AT LIKE
NINTH GRADE LEVEL- IN SO IN
COLLEGE IS THE FIRST TIME THAT-
I LEARNED HOW TO DO ALL THIS.
AND I THINK THAT THE WAY THAT
THESE THESE BEARS OVERCOME
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S A UNIQUE THING FOR ME I
THINK IT WAS IT WAS TRUE FOR
EVERYBODY PROJECT CHANGE RIGHT-
IT'S KATIE WAS VERY INTENTIONAL
WITH MAKING RELATIONSHIPS WITH-
PROFESSORS ON CAMPUS. THERE-
DATE WANTED TO SUPPORTERS. AND
SO OUR FIRST SEMESTER IN COLLEGE
LIKE. OR MY FIRST SEMESTER AND I
THINK FOR EVERY PROJECT CHANGE
STUDENT- SHE PICKED OUR CLASSES
AND PICKED A PROFESSORS- AND SO
MY- MY FIRST SEMESTER IN COLLEGE
I TOOK A FOR. A ETHNIC STUDIES
CLASS WITH THIS GUY NAMED RUDY
RAMIREZ- ACTUALLY PROFESSOR- HE
SAT ME DOWN HE TAUGHT ME HOW TO
DO MLA HE TELL ME HOW TO. HOW TO
WRITE- HE TOOK TIME OUT OF THE
OUT OF HIS DAY TO COME AND MEET
ME IN HIS OFFICE HOURS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT- AND HE'S
ACTUALLY STILL ONE OF MY IT LIKE
I WOULD CONSIDER HIM. A FRIEND I
WAS AT HIS HOUSE FOR LIKE A
PUBLIC A COUPLE WEEKS AGO HINA-
IN SO IT WAS ABOUT HAVING THOSE
THOSE KEY RELATIONSHIPS WITH.
WITH FACULTY AND PROFESSORS ON
CAMPUS- THAT WE'RE WILLING TO DO
THE EXTRA WORK- AND THAT REALLY
COMES FROM THE RELATIONSHIP
BUILDING COMMUNITY BUILDING-
THAT YOU SET THE STAGE WITH FOR.
THE YOUNG PEOPLE TO COME INTO.
THANK YOU. SO- KATIE THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF YOUR INVESTMENTS IF
YOU- WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
BARRIERS TO EXPANDING THIS MODEL
YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW PROJECT
CHANGES THAT THE COLLEGES AND
TWENTY SIX OTHER CULTURES HAVE
SOME SORT OF A PROGRAM SIMILAR
OUT THERE WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
BARRIERS TO EXPANDING THIS I'D
AND HAVING NETWORK OUT OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. SO I THINK.
WITH MOST THINGS ME FINANCIAL IS
A HUGE ASPECT BECAUSE THE THINGS
THAT THE STUDENTS ARE TALKING
ABOUT TO- IS ALSO THAT THERE IS
A DEDICATED SUPPORT ON THE
CAMPUS- FOR THIS KIND OF PROGRAM
STRUCTURE SO- FOR COLLEGE TO BE
ABLE TO HIRE SOMEONE AS A FULL
TIME POSITION TO BE ABLE TO RUN
A PROGRAM LIKE THIS- IS YOU KNOW
A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT COST- AND
IN OUR CASE. YOU KNOW I WAS AN
ADJUNCT AND THEN YOU KNOW TOOK
ON CERTAIN DUTIES AND WAS
CREATING IT WHILE I WAS TEACHING
AND SO ON AND SO FORTH AND THEN
EVENTUALLY YOU KNOW THAT COLLEGE
INVESTED THE FUNDS- TO BE ABLE
POSITION- BUT THAT'S RARE AND SO
IN ORDER FOR- YOU KNOW THE
MAJORITY OF COLLEGE CAMPUSES TO
BE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING LIKE
THIS IT REALLY DOES- THAT
DEDICATED. FUNDING STRUCTURE-
INCLUDING FOR COUNSELING STAFF-
AND A RETENTION SPECIALIST IS
THE STRUCTURE THAT'S BEEN
CREATED AT THIS POINT- AND WE'VE
SEEN THAT WITH YOU KNOW PROJECT
REBOUND I'M NOT UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS AND PROGRAMS THAT ARE
REALLY SUCCESSFUL LIKE THAT-
THAT IF SUPPORTED STUDENTS WHO
HAVE BEEN. THROUGH THE JUSTICE
SILT FILIPPIS CURRENTLY ALLOW
FOR THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM INSIDE.
SO IT I MEAN IT'S ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AT THIS POINT- I MEAN
THIS. THIS IS OBVIOUSLY SAN
MATEO COUNTY- BUT SAN FRANCISCO
IS DOING THIS WORK- AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH THEM- ALSO TO BE
ABLE TO. EXPAND THEIR
PROGRAMMING- L. A. COUNTY- SAN
DIEGO I MEAN THE LIST IS PRETTY
LONG- PALOMAR HE HASN'T SAN
DIEGO. ANYWAY IT'S QUITE
EXPENSIVE ACTUALLY WHERE PEOPLE
ARE ENGAGED IN THE WORK AT
DIFFERENT LEVELS- WERE EITHER
THEY HAVE YOU KNOW SOME
DEDICATED STAFF TIME FOR FOLKS
OR AND THEY HAVE A STUDENT CLUB
THAT SET UP- SO IT'S PIECES OF
THE PROGRAM FOR JUVENILE JUSTICE
BUT NOT THE FULL STRUCTURE. NINE
QUESTIONS- YOU GUYS HAVE ANY
LAST I GUESS ADVICE OR COMMENTS
YOU WANT TO SHARE WITH US. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US- AND AGAIN
JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THIS
IS REALLY AN EXCITING MOMENT
JUVENILE JUSTICE- AND LOOKING AT
THINGS DIFFERENT- FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION AND PATHWAYS SO- IT'S
GREAT TO. TAKE CONNECT WITH
OLIVIA. YEAH AND I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU GUYS FOR TAKING THE
TIME JUST TO EVEN LISTEN AND YOU
KNOW BE HERE I DO REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS YOU KNOW A
LOT OF DOES MEAN A LOT TO ME
BECAUSE- THIS IS BIG FOR ME SO.
I LOVE IT I APPRECIATE YOU GUYS
THANK YOU. COMPLETION YEAH OF US
A SEVERE EARTHQUAKE- I THINK
SOMETHING THAT THAT THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY IN
IN IN THE REALM OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE I IS IT- YOU HAVE
OPPORTUNITY TO STOP THE SCHOOL
TO PRISON PIPELINE RIGHT- SO YOU
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO STOP
PEOPLE FROM EVER GETTING INTO
PRISON AND- STOPPING THEM OTHER
YOUNG AND- THEIR BRAINS ARE
STILL DEVELOPING YOU YOU HAVE
THEY HAVE SO MUCH ABILITY TO. TO
CHANGE AND TO NOT EVEN
REHABILITATE BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
YOU CAN'T RESTORE SOMEBODY TO
SOMETHING THAT THEY NEVER WERE
RIGHT YOU GOT YOU HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD YOUNG
PEOPLE- INTO LEADERS AND- SO
HOPEFULLY ONE DAY THEY CAN SIT
NEXT TO YOU RIGHT- AND SO THAT
THEY CAN DO THIS WORK IN IN PUSH
IT FORWARD- IN UP FACETED JACKIE
SO SHE CAN SAY ANYTHING. YEAH
THINKING NECK- I JUST WANT TO
SAY JUST LIKE NICK SAID YOU
DEFINITELY- OF THE POWER TO.
MOVIES YOU THREE AND THEIR
FUTURES- BECAUSE THEY GET CAN
GET REALLY DIFFICULT TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT I MEAN WHEN I WAS
INCARCERATED I WISH THERE WAS A
PROGRAM THAT WOULD COME IN AND
SAY HEY- SOME CALL CLASSES YOU
CAN YOU CAN KERN AROMA WHILE
YOU'RE IN HERE YOU DON'T HAVE
TO. SIT IN THE CLASSROOM AND DO
A PACKET OF WORK BECAUSE YOU'RE
NOT ACT LEVEL- I WISH I HAD
SOMEONE TO COME IN AND TELL ME
THAT I WAS GOOD ENOUGH TO GO TO
COLLEGE THAT I WAS ABLE TO MAKE
IT JUST LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE HAS.
AND YOU KNOW I DIDN'T HAVE THAT
I HAVE TO SEEK OUT ON MY OWN
WHICH I WAS ABLE TO DO BUT IT
WAS NOT EASY TO DO AT ALL. AND
FEEL LIKE IF I WOULD HAVE HAD
THE SUPPORT SYSTEM THAT PROJECT
CHANGE OFFERS FROM THE TIME I
WAS IN JUVENILE HALL. I WOULD
HAVE. PROBABLY MY LIFE WILL
PROBABLY HAVE BEEN A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT EVEN THOUGH I'M VERY
PROUD OF WHERE I AM. BUT I
DEFINITELY WISH THAT I WOULD
HAVE GOT THAT HELP. AHEAD OF
TIME BECAUSE I COULD HAVE GOT
STARTED. EARLY SO I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE THE
IMPORTANT STUFF. PROGRAMS LIKE
THIS STATE MAKES SUCH A HUGE
IMPACT ON OUR LIVES AND- THEY
ARE A HUGE REASON WHY WE ARE
ABLE TO REACH THE LEVEL OF
SUCCESS THAT WE HAVE. SO YEAH
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HAVING US
HERE. HEY ALL THANK YOU FOR
MAKING TIME I WAS A LAST MINUTE
REQUEST WHEN I'M I WAS. EXCITED
TO BILL TO HIGHLIGHT- THIS THIS
PROGRAM. OUT THERE. AND LEARN A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
SUCCESSES- AND FOR THE THREE OF
YOU THE FOR ACTUAL- YOU KNOW I
TALK TO THE YOUTH IN MY
COMMUNITY ABOUT INVESTING IN
THEM. BECAUSE LIKE FOR THEM TO
COME BACK INVEST IN THE
COMMUNITY SO. APPRECIATIVE OF
THAT LEADERSHIP BUT YOU'LL HAVE
ALREADY. THINKING INTO ORGAN WE
WANT TO PUBLIC COMMENTS. AT THIS
POINT. DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM. OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
TELEPHONE EACH PERSON AT THE TWO
ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE NUMBER TO CONNECT TO THE
COMMITTEE- TO CONNECT THIS ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT'S ALSO
ON THE SCREEN OF YOUR STREAMING
THIS BUT JUST IN CASE ONE MORE
TIME THE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN IN THE ACCESS ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE
TWO SEVEN. OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALRIGHT THEN-
BUT THEN WE WILL GO AHEAD AND-
DURING TODAY'S MEETING THANK YOU
TO OUR PANELISTS INTO THE
MEMBERS HE'S A GIANT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AS. SO. BUT. YEAH.